anna we are in the northeast of russia
deep inside the arctic circle where
outside at the moment it is hot enough
to sunbathe
but i'm inside what is called a
permafrost cave
permafrost is the permanently frozen
layer of soil that sits
beneath a quarter of the northern
hemisphere
and as our planet warms and the arctic
is warming much faster
than the rest of the planet this layer
of soil
is beginning to thaw and that means that
the billions
of tons hundreds of billions of tons of
carbon trapped inside
is released i'll show you what that
means this
these roots are essentially plants that
were frozen
in the soil at the time when the
mammoths were roaming the grasslands
up above but as this stuff thaws this
decomposes
and greenhouse gases are emitted into
the atmosphere
methane and co2 and that warms up the
planet
further that is why this permafrost and
what happens to it
is really just as important in terms of
climate change in the arctic as
the melting ice caps and rising sea
levels